Fiery feathers, venomous spit, and jaws that
can crush an SUV.
"Jurassic World Dominion" features some of
the biggest and baddest dinos of the franchise,
but only one can claim victory over the others…
and it's done it more than once.
"Hold onto your butts."
Gallimimus is a long-necked egg-stealer whose
biggest claim to fame is probably being named
by young Tim in the original "Jurassic Park."
"Gala… uh…
Gallimimus!"
It's a fine dinosaur, and its ostrich-like
appearance definitely sets it apart from its
similarly sized cousins, but unfortunately
that's about all that Gallimimus has going
for it.
It isn't fearsome enough to get points in
the fright category, nor is it majestic enough
to rub shoulders with the sauropods, mostly
because those shoulders are way too high.
As the final nail in its coffin, Gallimimus
barely appears in "Jurassic World Dominion"
and provides little to the story or the thrills.
Perhaps that's just karmic justice for all
the eggs they've stolen over the years.
Our second-from-the-bottom spot is shared
by two different dinos alike in both size
and importance — the tiny Oviraptor and
equally small Moros intrepidus.
Moros intrepidus' biggest moment in "Dominion"
is a single shot where it's shown nibbling
between the teeth of the massive Giganotosaurus.
The little guy is cute, but he's used mostly
as a contrast to show how massive the Giganoto is.
Oviraptor occupies about the same amount of
screen time, stealing an egg in the film's
non-theatrical prologue and making an even
less memorable cameo later on in a pit fight scene.
Both Oviraptor and Moros intrepidus look cool,
but they don't stand up to the rest of the
dinos in the film, and they're too small to
make much of an impact, literally and figuratively.
If both dinos got credits at the end of the
film, they'd probably come below craft services.
On paper, Iguanodon is a pretty cool dinosaur.
It's a beefy herbivore with a beak-like snout
that can move on either two legs or four.
Unfortunately, "Jurassic World Dominion" doesn't
feature enough of the creature to earn it
a spot higher on this list.
The Iguanodon only appears in the film's non-theatrical
prologue which is set during the actual time
of the dinosaurs.
A group of them are shown grazing as two predators
approach, and they're never heard from again.
If you're an Iguanodon fan who was disappointed
by its minimal presence in "Jurassic World
Dominion," then you're in luck.
The 2000 Disney animated feature "Dinosaur"
casts the dino in the starring role.
Sure, the animation might be a little dated,
and the film didn't get rave reviews upon
its initial release, but a full theatrical
movie is more than most of the dinos here
have on their resumes.
When you think of the most iconic "Jurassic
Park" dinosaurs, the chicken-sized Compsognathus
may not be the first ones to come to mind,
but there's no denying that the little guys
belong on that short list as well.
From their horrific scene in "The Lost World:
Jurassic Park" to their numerous other appearances
throughout the franchise, Compsognathus is
a scary member of the Jurassic family.
They even get the better of John Hammond himself
in the original Michael Crichton novel after
Hammond breaks his ankle, attracting a large
pack of Compies that prey on the injured.
Sadly, the Compies don't get to do much in
"Jurassic World Dominion," and their most
notable appearance is during a stray shot
in the underground Malta dino market.
Still, they earn a slightly higher spot in
our ranking for two reasons: the merits of
their legacy in the franchise and their unshakeable
status as the best tiny dino in the business.
A much smaller cousin of the Spinosaurus,
Baryonyx is a long-snouted dinosaur that can
grow to a pretty impressive size.
The species makes an appearance in "Jurassic
World Dominion" fighting in the underground
dinosaur black market in Malta, where it's
seen battling in the pits against a young Allosaurus.
While Baryonyx doesn't have much in the way
of looks or power to rank above more notable
predators, the fact that it can hold its own
in a one-on-one is definitely enough to bump
it up at least a few spots.
The Malta fighting pits are some of the most
brutal examples of human cruelty to dinosaurs
shown in "Jurassic World Dominion," and there
are a bunch.
That makes Baryonyx not only a cool dino in
its own right but also an underdog story that's
definitely worth rooting for.
Maybe the one seen in Malta eventually makes
his way to the Dolomite sanctuary after the
dinos all escape.
Flying dinosaurs are cool — they just are.
They're basically the closest thing to dragons
Earth has ever seen.
Sadly, while the Pteranodon is the most famous
example of a winged dinosaur, its status as
de facto king of the primordial skies is usurped
in "Jurassic World Dominion" by other cooler
flying dinosaurs.
There are still a number of scenes that feature
the Pteranodon in all their glory, from their
bat-like wings to their long, skinny beaks
and pointy heads, but when compared to how
impressive the Pteranodons have been in previous
films, "Dominion" just falls a little short.
A lesser known winged dinosaur — the Dimorphodon
— shares the Pteranodon's place on this
list for a couple reasons.
While it is cool that the Dimorphodon's head
looks like a raptor or T-Rex, it doesn't get
to do nearly enough in the movie to justify
a higher position.
Within the context of "Jurassic World: Dominion,"
both of these dinos serve about the same purpose
— flying around and looking cool without
contributing much to the story.
Science shows that a spiky dinosaur is better
than a not-spiky dinosaur almost every time.
Of those spiky reptiles, Stegosaurus and Ankylosaurus
are probably the two most famous.
Whether you prefer Stego's vertical spines
or the Ankylosaurus' spikes and club-like
tail, these are undeniably two of the most
iconic dinos known to man.
It's fitting, then, that Ankylosaurus and
Stegosaurus share a spot on this list.
If either species had a notable role in "Jurassic
World: Dominion," that would be enough to
separate them, but they're both relegated
to the same fate — a handful of pretty vista
shots without any actual appearances in the
action.
For two less spectacular dinos, that would
be a cause for extinction, but because of
how great both are in any context, they still
get to stay in the middle tier of our ranking.
It also helps that both species feature in
such beautiful shots, which make their roles
memorable despite the lack of substantial
screen time.
Lots of dinosaurs have intimidating appearances,
but only one of them has a name that means
"Demon of the River Styx."
Known for its bone-hard skull and its spikes,
Stygimoloch is certainly an easy dino to pick
out in a crowd.
Even in the densely-packed Malta black market
full of illegally acquired species, Stygimoloch
sticks out like a sore thumb.
While it doesn't get to do much in "Dominion,"
this dino does give an intimidating stare
toward all the humans who pass by its underground
pen.
We can only assume that it exacts some vengeance
during the mass dino prison break, using its
powerful skull to free its prehistoric comrades
from captivity.
Stygimoloch gets some bonus points in "Jurassic
World: Dominion" for the hardships it endured,
as well as for simply being one of the coolest-looking
dinosaurs on the planet.
Who doesn't love a sauropod?
These long-necked, hump-backed, thick-legged
herbivores are some of the most iconic dinosaurs
ever discovered, and they've always played
a major role in the "Jurassic" movies.
Naturally majestic, they're often used to
cement the awe-inspiring nature of dinosaurs
in general, as in their famous debut in the
original "Jurassic Park."
"It's… it's a dinosaur."
For number 17 on our dino ranking, we're lumping
two of the big leaf-eaters together: Apatosaurus
and Brachiosaurus.
Apatosaurus might rank slightly higher here
since it gets a beautiful encounter with some
workers at a lumber yard in "Jurassic World:
Dominion," but it doesn't do enough to separate
itself from the Brachio.
As the larger and more vertical of the two,
Brachiosaurus still cuts a more impressive
figure, even if it plays a slightly smaller
role this time around.
Still, that early, snowy Apatosaurus scene
is undeniably impressive.
At number 16 on our list, it's our big-boy
carnivore: Allosaurus.
Smaller than a T-Rex but larger than a raptor,
the Allosaurus is most people's ideal of a
prehistoric predator with big hind legs, small
arms, claws, jaws filled with pointy teeth,
and a long, impressive tail.
Allosaurus is also the first dinosaur on this
list to have a more prominent role in "Jurassic
World: Dominion."
During the extended action sequence in Malta,
an Allosaurus and a Carnotaurus both escape
from an underground dino black market, leading
to a full-on brawl in the street.
It's a cool moment that's enough on its own
to earn Allosaurus a ranking this high.
Unfortunately, the Allosaurus is held back
from going any higher for one gigantic reason:
the Giganotosaurus.
The two dinosaurs look remarkably similar,
with the Giganoto even being mistaken for
a large Allosaurus at one point.
The comparison makes Allosaurus look a lot
less impressive and interesting, especially
given the huge role its doppelganger plays
later in the film.
It's easy for a dinosaur to be terrifying.
From their massive, scaly bodies to their
razor-sharp teeth, instilling fear isn't something
that most species have to work at.
Being cute, on the other hand, is a much more
daunting task for a dino.
After all, how many carnivorous reptiles actually
make you want to snuggle?
There are two species worthy of that honor
in "Jurassic World Dominion."
The first, Lystrosaurus, is seen in the Malta
black market.
She's a cutie who basically looks like a squat
and scaly pig, with a little bit of a Triceratops-type
skull plate.
She starts to snarl when all the action goes
down, but it only makes her more adorable.
The other dinosaur tied for this spot, Microceratus,
is exactly what it sounds like — a small,
triceratops-like creature with an adorable
face.
While larger than the Lystrosaurus, Microceratus
also makes the audience squeal at its cuteness,
offering a brief break from all the murderous
rampaging.
"Yeah… that's nice… gotta go."
No one has a longer head than Parasaurolophus,
which counts for something in itself.
This chunky, largely peaceful dino has been
used as set dressing in past films, given
how majestic the species looks when moving
in a herd.
That's still largely how the Parasaurolophus
is used in "Jurassic World Dominion," but
it gets a bit more time in the spotlight.
Not only is it the dino in Owen's introductory
scene where he chases a pack of the creatures
on horseback like a prehistoric cowboy — but
it also has a touching moment that's used
to help us sympathize with the dinosaurs.
After having a heck of a time wrestling one
of the herbivores to a standstill, Owen manages
to calm it with some sweet words and gentleness.
A final scene shows the Parasaurolophus running
alongside wild horses, helping us see them
as animals, not monsters.
Who doesn't love a good sea monster?
After prominent turns in "Jurassic World"
and "Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom," the
Mosasaurus takes a step back in importance
in "Dominion," but not enough to knock it
too far down this list.
There's simply nothing else like the Mosasaurus
— from its gaping maw and massive flippers
to the sheer terror it inflicts every time
it shows up on screen, it's a monster of a
dino that's in 20,000 leagues of its own.
Additionally, the few scenes that the Mosasaurus
does get in "Jurassic World Dominion" still
manage to take our breath away.
It kicks the film into high gear at the very
start by attacking an innocent fishing trawler
in brutal fashion.
In a nice contrast, it ends the film by swimming
peacefully by some ordinary whales.
The land-based dinosaurs may get more screen
time overall, but there's something unique
about the ocean-based Mosasaurus that's still
unmatched.
After menacing multiple dinosaurs in Disney's
"Dinosaur" and hunting human campers in the
animated series "Jurassic World: Camp Cretaceous",
Carnotaurus finally gets a chance to shine
in live action when it appears in "Jurassic
World Dominion."
A Carnotaurus escapes from the Malta black
market early in the film and quickly begins
laying waste to the city, battling an Allosaurus
and devouring some innocent bystanders along
the way.
While it technically has the same basic role
as the Allosaurus, Carnotaurus gets a leg
up for two reasons.
First, it just looks cooler.
That blood-red color and the horns on its
head give the Carnotaurus a top-tier intimidation
factor, even when compared to other carnivores.
Second, it doesn't suffer from the Giganotosaurus
comparisons the same way that Allosaurus does.
Fast, vicious, and just plain awesome, Carnotaurus
is a fearsome predator in its own right, and
it deserves the number 12 spot on our list.
On its best days, Triceratops easily gets
a top-five spot on a favorite dinosaur list.
It's got the look, the toughness, and the
celebrity status.
Unfortunately for fans of the three-horned
species, Triceratops doesn't get much real
screen time in "Jurassic World Dominion."
The good news is that some of the other, less
famous members of the ceratopsian family finally
get some well-deserved spotlight shone on
them in the film.
Claire and her crew save a baby Nasutoceratops
— a species with only the two top horns
— from illegal dino breeders.
Later, a herd of adult Nasutoceratops return
the favor by taking down the pursuing dino
breeders, allowing Claire and her team to
escape.
A Sinoceratops — possessing just the faceplate
and rhino-like nose horn of the Triceratops
— also shows up in the film, most prominently
in the closing montage that shows how different
dinosaurs are becoming part of Earth's modern
ecosystem.
Some of the species are seen walking alongside
a herd of elephants across what appears to
be the African savanna, giving viewers a nice
little bit of majestic lumbering before the
credits roll.
The first dinosaur to make it into our top
10 is none other than Dreadnoughtus, a sauropod
of truly mammoth proportions.
While it doesn't get as much individual attention
in "Jurassic World Dominion" as the Apatosaurus,
it earns a higher spot because of its impressive
size.
The fact that it's never appeared in all its
glory in the franchise before just makes its
scenes more significant.
Simply put, the Dreadnoughtus is awe-inspiring.
It's one of the first dinosaurs that Dr. Alan
Grant and Dr. Ellie Sattler see during their
flyover of Biosyn's Dolomite Mountains sanctuary,
and it's a perfect choice to drive home just
how big and impressive the whole operation
is.
Introducing Dreadnoughtus feels like both
a nod and an attempt at one-upping the sauropod
reveal in the first "Jurassic Park."
The effect is impressive — just not as magical
this time around.
Typically, Pteranodons have been the masters
of the sky in the "Jurassic" franchise.
In "Jurassic World Dominion," however, that
title is snatched and carried even higher
into the air by Quetzalcoatlus.
Not only does the winged beast look positively
gnarly with its gargoyle-ish head and feathery,
clawed body, it also stars in one of the film's
most frightening moments.
While flying over the Dolomite sanctuary,
Kayla, Owen, and Claire are thrown into a
terrifying airborne battle when a Quetzalcoatlus
chooses their airplane for an evening snack.
The creature tears the vessel to pieces in
record time, forcing Claire to eject and Kayla
and Owen to attempt a dangerous crash-landing.
Everyone ends up surviving, but it's still
a heart-pounding ordeal that gives this flying
dinosaur a top spot on this list.
Biosyn's Dolomite dinosaur sanctuary is home
to a number of more obscure species who've
never been seen before in the franchise.
One of those is Dimetrodon, a creature that
precedes most proper dinosaurs, and who provides
a heavy scare to Alan Grant, Ellie Sattler,
and Maisie Lockwood in the film.
While escaping from Biosyn's facility, the
trio comes across a Dimetrodon in the tunnels,
and it very nearly brings their journey to
an abrupt and violent end.
Ramsey and Ian Malcolm save them in the nick
of time, but it's still pretty close.
Being the star of such a big action scene
is enough to net Dimetrodon a high spot on
this list, but the species is boosted even
higher by its unique look.
Adequately described as a massive alligator
with the back fin of a Spinosaurus, it's an
imposing creature that you definitely wouldn't
want to run into in a dark tunnel.
The Dilophosaurus occupies a very unique space
in the world of "Jurassic Park."
Despite its small size, it's one of the most
feared dinosaurs in the "Jurassic Park" franchise,
largely because of the way it blinds Dennis
Nedry with its venom in the first film before
attacking him.
Nedry is a pretty reprehensible villain, and
the desire to see him get what's coming to
him is satisfied when he comes face to face
with a Dilophosaurus.
From the Dilophosaurus' neck frills to the
terrifying goop it spews to its hoarse call,
this species is extremely memorable.
All of those characteristics are present when
the creature returns in "Jurassic World Dominion"
to exact another batch of poetic justice.
When Lewis Dodgson — the Biosyn CEO who
originally commissioned Nedry to steal embryos
from the first Jurassic Park — tries to
escape his own fallen kingdom, he comes face
to face with a group of dinos.
And just like the man he once hired, Dodgson
meets his gruesome end at the claws of the
Dilophosaurus.
It's a nice full-circle moment that earns
the dino a top spot on this list.
After being the de facto dinosaur protagonist
of the prior two films, Blue the Velociraptor
takes a surprising back seat in "Jurassic
World Dominion."
She has a decent amount of screen time at
the beginning of the film, but she doesn't
join in any of the action later.
Perhaps the filmmakers figured that people
were sick of Velociraptors always being the
smartest and most dangerous dinosaurs in the
room, making Blue decide to take a long-overdue vacation.
"Clever girl."
Regardless, the Velociraptor as a species
still earns the number seven spot on this
list because of Blue's child, Beta.
While undeniably still a threat, Beta is more
cute than scary, and the little dino has plenty
of great moments throughout the film.
From learning how to hunt from its momma to
escaping from Biosyn's laboratories with Maisie,
Beta shows us a different side of the Velociraptors
that feels fresh and entertaining.
And did we mention how cute Beta is?
Despite being the big bad of "Jurassic World:
Dominion," the Giganotosaurus barely squeezes
its way into our top five.
Before we get to what's holding it back, let's
focus on what's great about this dinosaur.
A larger predator than even the Tyrannosaurus
rex, Giganotosaurus definitely has some wow
factor due to its sheer size.
It also has a number of exciting moments,
from its showdown with the humans, where Ian
Malcolm throws a flaming spear in its mouth,
to its duel with the T-Rex in the movie's climax.
It absolutely accomplishes what a "Jurassic"
villain dino needs to do — look big and
scary and trash everything.
"Bigger.
Why do they always have to go bigger?"
Unfortunately, that's also the problem with
the Giganotosaurus.
For all of the buildup that it receives, it
doesn't really do anything that we haven't
already seen in the franchise.
It's as if the writers took some of the T-Rex's
best scenes from all of the past films and
just swapped in a slightly larger, less famous
dinosaur.
As a result, even Giganoto's most exciting
moments are hindered by a feeling of "been
there, done that."
By the time the T-Rex shows back up to take
it on, you'll probably catch yourself cheering
— not because you're so excited about the
coming battle, but because the movie finally
gave you the carnivores you actually wanted
to see.
Clocking in at number four is the dinosaur
that largely steals the Velociraptor's thunder,
its cousin, the Atrociraptor.
Seen solely in the Malta sequence, Biosyn's
purebred Atrociraptors are some of the fastest
and most lethal dinosaurs ever seen in a "Jurassic"
movie.
The recipients of intensive training, they
go after Owen and Claire with lethal intensity,
leading to a tense chase scene where the dinos
reveal they can run just as fast as motorcycles and trucks.
"Must go faster."
The Malta pursuit is definitely one of the
standout moments in "Jurassic World Dominion,"
and that's mostly because of the Atrociraptors.
It's also nice to see the franchise find a
way to put a new twist on the timeless appeal
of the Velociraptors, even if it only lasts
for a few minutes.
That being said, the Atrociraptor isn't the
best "Dominion" dino to bear the raptor family
name on this list, but more on that later..
Red, feathered, and wielding some truly impressive
claws, Therizinosaurus is one of the most
unique and interesting dinosaurs in "Jurassic
World: Dominion."
From its quiet stalking of Claire in the Dolomites
to its accidental victory over the Giganotosaurus,
Therizinosaurus leaves a lasting impression,
which is probably why it was featured so heavily
in the film's trailers.
There's simply never been a dinosaur like
the Therizinosaurus in a "Jurassic" movie before.
It looks like what Freddy Krueger would become
if he were a prehistoric bird, which is enough
to make it the stuff of nightmares.
Then there's the fact that it's featured in
such a prominent role during the film's final act.
As fun as it is to see classic dinos like
the T-rex and the Triceratops, it's arguably
even more fun to see a lesser-known species
used in a new and creative way.
That's exactly what the Therizinosaurus delivers
in "Dominion," earning it the bronze medal.
There's so much to love about the Pyroraptor
that it's honestly hard to know where to start.
For starters, it has a rad name that's perfectly
suited to its fiery feathers.
Second, it stars in arguably the most exciting
dino encounter in "Jurassic World: Dominion."
Facing off against a raptor of any sort with
nothing more than knives and a taser to defend
yourself is already a tough task, but doing
it on a sheet of thin ice?
That's just ridiculous.
The Pyroraptor makes a big impression with
its sharp cries and incredible speed, but
the fact that it can swim makes it even cooler.
"What an a—hole"
Sadly, the Pyroraptor is a one-and-done dino.
It would have been cool to see him show up
later like the Therizinosaurus, but maybe
that wouldn't have fit into an already packed
third act.
Nevertheless, the Pyroraptor easily takes
home the silver medal, as well as the title
of best raptor in the entirety of "Jurassic
World Dominion."
Did you expect something different?
"Jurassic Park" has tried many times to replace
the T-Rex as the biggest and baddest dinosaur around.
Suffice it to say, that's never worked out.
From its hulking skull to its tiny arms and
iconic roar, there's just too much to love
about the Tyrannosaurus for it to ever be
usurped.
Rexy doesn't even have that much screen time
in "Jurassic World Dominion," yet she dominates
every second of it.
Her crowning moment is her climactic duel
with the Giganotosaurus — an absolute slugfest
of mammoth proportions that decimates the
surrounding area.
And while the T-Rex does seem to go down for
the count at one point, she gets by with a
little help from her friends.
A tiny distraction is all she needs to get
back on her feet and deliver a brutal body
blow to her opponent, knocking the Giganoto
directly into the talons of the Therizinosaurus
and impaling it.
Rexy roars her trademark roar as the world
burns around her, declaring she's still, unequivocally,
the queen.